merci Madame la Président Madame le
Premier ministre depuis des semaines
vous évoquez la réforme des retraites
mais vous préoccupez-vous vraiment du
bien-être de nos aînés en vous posant
cette question je veux parler de la
fameuse loi grand âge évoquée par le
président en 2018 il y a déjà 5 ans
tellement attendu et qui aujourd'hui est
resté l'être morte la situation de nos
aînés préoccupe toutes nos familles mais
également l'ensemble des personnels qui
ont à cœur de les accompagner avec
bienveillance et empathie
il n'est pas admissible aujourd'hui que
tout soit aussi oublié que nos soignants
soient autant malmenés car leur métier
est un beau et noble métier il s'occupe
des plus fragiles dans leur quotidien en
donnant toute leur énergie pour à la
fois soulager leur souffrance et aussi
parfois leur solitude je ne compte plus
les témoignages d'animateurs
d'aide-soignant d'infirmiers
d'associations ou encore de directeurs
d'établissements qui me font part de
leur détresse d'une réelle détresse
quant à leur difficulté de continuer à
exercer leur mission avec humanité nos
grands-parents nos parents méritent que
le gouvernement prenne toute la mesure
de l'enjeu d'une politique d'ampleur sur
ce sujet tous nous devons nous sentir
concernés car toutes les familles
peuvent être confrontées à des
difficultés encore hier la Défenseur des
droits dans son dernier rapport indiqué
que depuis les révélations scandale du
lien non aucune réponse concrète n'a été
apportée alors ce n'est pas
d'administratif supplémentaire dans les
établissements ont besoin au contraire
ils ont besoin d'une valorisation de ces
six beaux métiers de recrutement massifs
d'investissement majeurs pour répondre
aux demandes et accompagner ceux qui ont
tant donné à la France et qui ont
aujourd'hui besoin de nous alors madame
le Premier ministre quand allez-vous
enfin faire du grand âge une de votre
priorité